the name's duction detective D duction
I'm a private eye and my eye is pointed
straight at Monetary Mysteries love them
Financial Tom Foolery dollar double
dealing that's my wheelhouse and no
mistake there's one case I keep coming
back to turning it over over and over in
my mind like a tarnished todrey old coin
I call it the case of the early
bird there were two friends see Miguel
and Jasmine both worked for the same
firm both made the exact same income
both hired in fact on the very same day
wow what an honor it is to work at
widget Corp yes I love making widgets
there's so such great abstract units of
production when they filled out their
onboarding paperwork they had to answer
a series of questions like if they
wanted to contribute to a 401k savings
account health insurance yes dental
insurance yes retirement um yes I heard
it's good to save why not
$25 eh I'll start contributing later I'm
too young to start thinking about
retirement this is my first
job let me get used to the salary first
you know so Miguel contributed
$25 per paycheck and Jasmine contributed
zero years past widget Corp continued to
make widgets Miguel and Jasmine
continued to be friends and Miguel
continued to contribute
$25 automatically deducted from every
paycheck to his 401k and he never
thought about it again what Stellar
employees and can you believe we got
them both on the very same day here's to
another 10 years of Jasmine and Miguel
congratulations you two thank you for
all the work you've done for witchet
core
awesome I love widgets widgets we've
loved working here thank you thanks
y'all keep treating us this well and
we'll never retire you'll get sick of us
speaking of retiring yeah should I
contribute to my 401k I would I think
I'm still contributing to mine on Monday
you should talk to Bryce in HR he'll get
you set up perfect but okay more
importantly how was your kid's first day
at school oh man she cried so much oh no
but when she came home she was so
excited to go again after 10 years
Jasmine decided to start contributing to
her 401k to catch up up to Miguel she
doubles her contribution $50 per
paycheck Miguel keeps his contribution
the same $25 per paycheck keep those
numbers in
mind years pass another 30 years in fact
fortunes Rose and fell Hearts broke and
were mended children grew and married
and had children of their own Miguel and
Jasmine grew old and comfortable and
both of them decid decided to retire 40
years at widget Court Jazz that's a long
time to do one thing we made some good
widgets Millan we made some great
widgets but I'm ready for something new
and here's where the mystery comes in
ladies germs and py DMS here's where the
big old walloping Whopper of a mystery
strides into
view who do you think has more money at
retirement is it Miguel who saved $25
per paycheck for 40 years or Jasmine who
save $50 per paycheck for 30 years place
your bets folks who do you think ended
up with more money pause your video here
if you want to think about it a
little if you guess Jasmine you were
wrong when they looked at their
retirement accounts Miguel had around
$168,000 and Jasmine had
$147,000 hot dog so there you have it
the mystery of the missing Moola where
did all that extra money come from and
why did Miguel have so much more of it
than jasman did I tore up the city
looking for leads until I realized the
culprit had been in front of me this
whole time it was my old friend compound
interest wasn't it compound pound a jeez
D you can just call me CI all right cool
it with the fire brigade I'm on the
level what did you do to Jasmine's money
you loow down scheming Aly rat I grew it
same as anyone jeez if you'd put me down
for 10 seconds I'll explain it to you
I'm all your
CI so you know how I operate right yeah
yeah I saw it on Con Academy I'm no
Janie come lately the longer you operate
the bigger the pile of dough exactly
even though Jasmine saved for 30 years
and it double the rate of Miguel
Miguel's extra 10 years of savings meant
that he had more time for the interest
to compound even though he invested a
smaller amount of money you're saying
that even with his smaller contributions
he still outpaced Jasmine slow and
steady wins the race de the earlier you
start saving for retirement the better
off you'll be even if it's just a couple
of bucks they start adding up so that
was it the secret to Miguel's success
uccess was that he started early and he
didn't even think about it he set up an
autod deduct from every paycheck that
pav the road to his success and thanks
to that weird little turnip compound
interest see I'm standing right here he
managed to increase his little Nest Egg
big time it tells you something it's a
little voice at first but it gets louder
and louder it says don't wait the best
time to start saving is today it's never
too early to save for your
retirement I'm just a private eye I
don't know what the rate of return is
going to be but I'll tell you this the
longer you save the more money you'll
get back when you
retire saving for a rainy day is never a
bad idea because in a town like this
precipitation is
expected